how do you respond to the competition
look whatever business you're in there's
going to be tons of competition
if there's no direct competition you
have indirect competition
you look at something that's brand new
you look at you look at the tesla
electric roadsters maybe nobody's done
that before but what are people are
buying they're buying other cars right
you always have competition and they're
always going to be aggressive
everybody wants to win you're going to
have
constantly aggressive competition so how
do you respond when they
reduce their prices should you reduce
your prices too what do you do as a
result
the most important thing here is with
your business you have to have something
that sets you apart
okay it's not just whatever product or
service you're selling there's
has to be something unique about your
business how you offer it
so that when people come to you they're
not
you don't have a direct competition that
they're going up against
they're buying you for a specific reason
because nobody can offer
the quality of service or the line of
product that you have
you have to give them a reason to want
to buy from you over somebody else
this comes as a result from a question
on my newsletter list
tayo who wrote in to say i have a
question what's the best thing to do
when a direct
competitor reduces their prices do you
reduce your prices offer discounts have
promotions
what do you do i look forward to hearing
from you taiyo great question
and the loser's game is to start
reducing your prices
because you're just going to race to the
bottom and you're going to end up
undercutting each other undercutting
each other undercutting each other
and end up with no money left right
entrepreneurs we
don't charge enough and it's because
we're not bringing enough value you
gotta
figure out a way to not worry so much of
competition and bring
more value to your customers because
there's always a cheaper option
whether it's your store down the street
whether it's a guy
online whether it's your high school you
know
nephew there's always competition it's
always a cheaper option going with you
and you don't want to be the cheapest
option that is never the path
to long term success you can't compete
on price
you have to add more value and stand out
here's an example companies will hire me
to create content for their website
okay you want me to write a blog post
for your site it's going to cost you
2500 bucks
2 500 bucks maybe that takes me half an
hour to write
that's gonna be the best blog post
that's ever gone up on your site you're
gonna have more shares you're gonna have
more likes you're gonna have more
engagement than you've ever seen
on your website and companies will come
to me and say 2 500 bucks for like half
an hour of work
i could get somebody to do it for 500
bucks i get something to do for 100
bucks you can get people to do it for
free i don't care
it's not going to be as good you're
coming to me because you want me
because i've separated myself i've
differentiated myself and i'm working
with ideal clients if you don't have the
budget
to afford that 2500 bucks then i'm not
working with you i'm working with
different clients
and you're going to have the guys who
come to you only for price
you cut your price you're going to have
new clients you raise your prices those
super price cautious customers are going
to go those aren't the guys you want
you want the people who see the value in
your business and it starts with you
adding value so whatever product it is
that you're selling
you got to figure out a way to add more
value to it
to either create your own new line to
add something to that product so it's
not
being sold the exact same product by
your competition
you add a level of service on top of it
that nobody can match
something you've got to figure out a way
to add more value
and then only work with the clients who
are ideal clients who love this stuff
who eat this stuff up people who value
the servers
people who value the extra work you're
putting in and don't worry about the
rest of the guys
let your competition fight to the bottom
of the barrel for the low price guys
there's always room at the top for
quality go to the top
be the best at what you do attract the
loyal following
and you can charge them more for
whatever you're selling stop worrying
about the competition
and focus on adding value to your
customer believe
for those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below
makes want to do more and leave a
comment below
leave a comment please let me know what
you think you have a question put it
below make a video response thank you so
much
and i'll see you soon
you